jahres das ist es nicht aber es ist der
emotionale höhepunkt des jahres war für
mich der zapfenstreich das thema des
jahres das weiß jeder für nach acht
zuschauer ist für mich die korona
pandemie und meine kritik daran aber
heute habe ich mir gedacht wenn beenden
möchte ich nicht über corona sprechen
jetzt habe ich doch getan aber ich bin
nicht direkt weiter los mit dem
zapfenstreich der kanzlerin ich muss
zugeben für mich ist angela merkel ein
vorbild was auch die europäische
stabilität betrübt aus mehreren gründen
sie war ein garant dafür aber vor allem
der stand in der welt ich möchte dieses
marken leute nicht klauen hat die german
angst vertrieben wird uns beliebt
gemacht in der welt man hand zu uns
aufgeschaut durch sie und ich bin ihr
sehr dankbar dass sie auch ein vorbild
weil ich nur für mich sondern für die
generation von frauen warum war sie so
ein vorbild als kammerherr ist jetzt
vize präsidentin wurde hat sie die rede
gehalten ich bin die erste aber ich
werde nicht die letzte sein und ich habe
in dem moment gedacht zum glück war
angela merkel nie so angela merkel war
einfach eine frau ohne immer sagen zu
müssen dass sie eine frau ist das halt
ein ganz neues selbstbewusstsein auch
den frauen in diesem land gebracht und
wieso war es für mich der emotionale
höhepunkt weil als sie dann deutschland
um hat gesehen wie sie mit den tränen
kämpfte ich war 13 jahre alt als sie
unsere kanzlerin wurde und als ich dann
die kapelle gehört hat wieder nina
hagens lied erklang hatte ich auch wo
sich sagen tränen augenblicks berührend
fand sie gehen zu sehen und deswegen
finde ich schon dass man sagen muss bei
aller kritik die man an ihr haben kann
wenn über krone jetzt reden würde er
dies wäre die kritik an ihr aber für
mich war das ein emotionaler höhepunkt
des jahres diese große frau gehen zu
sehen
ja
lena ich werde ihm gar nicht
widersprechen weil ich finde jeder
sollte sollte diese 16 jahre so
beurteilen wie er das fühlt und es ist
schon mal eine leistung per se 16 jahre
in einem solchen amt zu haben sich
solche größten krisen dass durch den
völlig märz hat sehr diskutiere ich fand
ich gesagt ist eine tolle leistung nicht
mit den füßen voran hinten raus getragen
zu werden aus dem kanzleramt aber das
war ja auch völlig deplatziert aber hier
in diesem fall ist es so dass man dass
man anerkennen und das ist wirklich
schon einmal per se eine große leistung
und einsatz
nur ich fand gerade diesen zapfenstreich
auch ein bisschen ja verstörend bei ich
ich war wie viele andere glaube ich auch
sehr überrascht auf der liedauswahl von
angela nicht so großartig ja ist ja ist
ja wohl aber jemand hat geschrieben
glaubt bei daily mail war im grunde
zeigt dass das niemand angela merkel
wirklich kannte und du mit den positiven
jagen sie hat uns immer wieder
überrascht nicht aber niemand hatte doch
darauf dass sie dieses dieses billig
sagt das ja erklärt weil ein kind mit
ihrer kindheit und ist man noch was ist
eigentlich überrascht darf ich sagen
warum zum beispiel gern schröder hatte
doch frank sinatra meint ja es wurde
also im gegensatz gesagt dieses macho
liegen es war ein verstörender ich
möchte ist nicht mehr jene hagen
vergleichen ich finde auch nicht das
budget ist ich fand's super gerät für
gerd schröder aber dass gegen lieb ist
hildegard knef für mich soll's rote
rosen regnen sie hat von drei liedern
zwei weibliche nieder sie redet nie
darüber dass frauen und feminismus und
so aber wieder bei der auswahl ihrer
lieder waren zwei kunden sollten wir die
aus gadeland nicht wieder passiert das
also überlegt sich dass der kanzler mich
richtig die haben ja die jeder hier hat
ja die wahl drei lieder dann zu seinem
abschied zu werden büro
und manchmal kommt irgendwann können
haben ein frühstück oder sonstwo aber
man überlegt schon eine zeit angegangen
wird bei angela genauso gewesen sein
work gerd schröder was wären die lieder
die passen und und dann gibt es
natürlich eins was meistens ein etwas
getragen ist oder ein eher klassisches
liedes und dann zwei oder eins etwas
werden würde ich sagen ist sagt jetzt
nicht so wahnsinnig viel aus doch
absolute ja bei gerd schröder war es
dann auch noch mackie messer
durch das hat er selbst gemacht hat sich
ja auch aber ich fand es wunderbar für
ihn passiert das auch in my way am ende
da gab es ja auch eine träne zumindest
im auge also das ist ein hoch
emotionaler moment nach einer einer
kanzlerschaft daneben endgültig dann
abschied zu nehmen und da spielen die da
rein deswegen ist das ein ganz
persönlicher moment ja also ich finde
wenn wir sozusagen angela merkels
kanzlerschaft gerade mit der von gerhard
schröder vergleichen fehlt mir so ein
bisschen das projekt die reform die
übrig bleibt von dem also wenn man sich
überlegen gerhard schröder mit immer in
die geschichte eingehen agenda 2010 und
eine unglaubliche leistung für dieses
land helmut schmidt mehrere dinge war
für mich dann natürlich der nato
doppelbeschluss der letztlich der
letztlich zum fall der mauer eigentlich
unmittelbar gefühlen hat helmut kohl
auch mit sieben schoß gefallen ist erst
der kanzler der einheit kann mir einer
von euch sagen wofür merkel steht gehört
sagt nicht krisenbewältigung wofür steht
ein programm hat was ich meine es was
ich meinem statement gesagt habe ich
finde dass wir das unterschätzen denn
sie steht dafür dass das ausland und
auch wir den german angst überwunden
haben und das muss man sagen kann also
vielleicht spricht einem dach hinein aus
diesem geschehen wäre nicht haye solches
mangelndes deutsches mm
selbstbewusstsein da für mich der
deutsche selbstbewusstsein wieder zurück
geholt hat war für mich gerhard schröder
gerhard schröder der als erstes geht der
der gegenüber amerika aufgestanden ist
und gesagt hat wir machen diesen krieg
nicht mit jahre später kamen dann alle
anderen und andere objekte plate hätten
tony blair und alle anderen haben sich
immer über mussten mussten viel viel
kreide fressen mussten zugeben dass das
ein fehler war gerhard schröder ist
aufgestanden gerhard schröder hat für
mich deutsch-deutsches selbstbewusstsein
zurück war aber immer aufs ausland zu
schauen und zu sagen harvey sehen uns
die franzosen wir sehen uns die enge das
zeigt dort das zeigt doch für ein
mangelndes
angela merkel ja in allen abschieden und
allen rückblick immer gesagt wurde sie
war die kanzlerin der krisen und alleine
deswegen hat sie das gut gemacht sie
haben das so sie hatte drei große krisen
das scheint sie hatte die
finanzmarktkrise dient sie an der seite
von peer steinbrück bewältigen gibt
bewältigt gemeinsam mit steinbrück und
mit oder auf kosten aber minister also
das war wirklich eine leistung der
großen koalition das zweite war die
flüchtlingskrise die hat die cdu
geschreddert bis heute das muss man
sagen in ihrem werk in ihrem kern nicht
zerstört aber angegriffen und sie hat
die korona krise und in diesen beiden
letzten krisen hat sie eigentlich nicht
geführt sie hat irgendwann mal eine
entscheidung getroffen ist ja die nicht
hinreichend begründet bei der
flüchtlingskrise und sie hat die folgen
nicht abgearbeitet zumindest nicht
kommunikativ und das kann man ihr
wirklich
nach diesen 16 jahren vorhalten dass sie
eben der von hinten geführt hat und
nicht von vorne an die politik ihren
kollidiert in eine andere sichtweise
noch sagen zb 215 ich weiß es wird ja
auch von der mehrheit der deutschen so
gesehen mit der flüchtlingskrise ich
muss sagen für mich war es nach wie vor
eine humanitäre aktion ischen ausmaßen
gleichung wir waren mit dabei und haben
mit somit die formel geprägt refugees
world also sofern man bei der live dabei
und wird dabei ich meine nicht weil das
klang ein live dabei
läuft sobald ich bin aber ihre freunde
für mich was definitiven akt historische
ausmaße humanitärer akt und ich finde
dass zum beispiel diese entscheidung
weiter durch zeit man sagt ja immer sie
sowieso ein fisch gewesen immer von
links nach rechts geht thema atomenergie
und bei der flüchtlingskrise dass auch
auszuhalten die kritik dabei zu bleiben
bei dem kurs das fand ich also für mich
hat sie da schon hochachtung also nicht
hat friedrich merz hat kreide gefressen
ich hab gefragt habe das gefühl hat
kreide gefressen was ist denn endlich
gehört schon nochmals zu corona und
merkt dass da kann ich ganz viel sagen
da war sie auch nicht mehr meine
kanzlerin also dachte ich ich habe eben
im statement deswegen war kohl an sich
komplett das ist aber immer genannt ja
aber aber in einer moment das muss ich
ganz klar sagen was in der korona
pandemie passiert ist da bin ich immer
noch nach wie vor erschrocken und ich
würde auch sagen der zapfenstreich hätte
vielleicht vier jahre er sein sollen
aber nicht nur wegen koma ich halte 16
jahre generell zu lang also ich glaube
wir sollten schon mal in deutschen
darüber legen eine amtszeit zu begrenzen
das kann bilder besser beurteilen als
ich aber es ist ja hochleistungssport
auch das meist gar nicht welcher mensch
16 jahre fährt jetzt ganz normal über
die möglicherweise größten fehler von
angela merkel sprechen zu besser
vorbereiten jahren auch ein bisschen du
bist österreicher hast du ein bisschen
ja ich halte mich dann natürlich etwas
zurück das ist eure kanzlerin gewesen
aber sie war natürlich einer der
stärksten figuren europas und hat die eu
politik mitbestimmt nie kennen wie keine
zweite
euro krise hat sie bewältigt hat ja auch
europa etwas gespalten da würde ich
sagen angela merkel war dafür
prädestiniert europa öfters mal zu
spalten flüchtlingskrise kann man gut
finden was sie getan hat das war aber
nicht abgesprochen mit europa und hat
die ganze eu vor sehr sehr viele
fragezeichen gestellt und auch sehr auf
die branche kann auch sagen sie hat den
populistischen parteien in ganz europa
auf die beine gestellt sie hatten sie
hat dafür gesorgt dass in ungarn und in
polen strecke ressentiments gegenüber
sie jetzt vielleicht sogar den dreck
sieht ausgelöst wenn du so willst europa
ich möchte eine sache noch loswerden die
zeitung politiken die ich sehr schätze
naja muss man das jetzt im full
disclosure sagen dass sie aus dem
springer-verlag poly control ist
inzwischen sehr viel lieber als nikon um
spd politiker hat sich mal vorgenommen
diesen mythos auf den grund zu gehen
merkel die krisenkanzlerin ist jede
krise durchgegangen und die politiker
ist wirklich kein blatt das mit schaum
vorm mund sondern ganz sachlich daran
geht die frühere economist und des
quintessenz des des politiker war sie
war eine kanzlerin die die krisen immer
nur geträumt hat unter den teppich
gekehrt hat und nie wirklich
substanziell gelöst haben wir doch die
krisen durch die finanzkrise das geht
auf kosten unserer sparer und rentner
bis heute unseren unsere nullzinspolitik
bedeutet dass unsere rentner und sparer
dafür zahlen dass sind das in italien
und in griechenland die pensionen und
ausgesagt der wehr wo